So the specific objectives of this lesson are for
us to learn, in detail, how does the aperture, the shutter speed, and
ISO which is basically the sensitivity of the film or the sensor,
together form a triangle, let's you then control the exposure of the image
that you're trying to capture, based on the light that's coming into the camera.
Exposure triangle is a well known concept in photography.
And the reason we want to cover it here is,
we want to be able to learn about the different aspects of a picture or
an image that's actually captured on a camera by controlling things like
the aperture size, the shutter speed, and the sensitivity.
And these are, of course, the three aspects of the exposure triangle that camera
operators use to be able to take the photograph that they're interested in.
We will also show you various types of examples today.
As to what variations of each one of them.
And how it impacts what kind of an image you get.